we also saw a documentary we cried
yesterday and was about the Boston
Marathon bombings it was on HBO go if
you don't have HBO go
what's on HBO yeah and it literally made
us cry so hard especially to two
brothers they follow the two brothers
and no not so you you think you know we
know everything essentially about the
bombing right music yeah but then it
this one goes into the individual lives
of the victims and a lot of them where
were family members so it's like two
brothers and then newlyweds and then a
mom and daughter
you know when they lost like limbs
together they were in a hospital
together but there's this particular
scene where these two these two brothers
right were literally at the epicenter of
I think the second bomb yeah the second
right and they lost their legs you know
and they were in two different hospitals
in the beginning and so they were able
to see each other and they were there
from a month or whatever yeah one of
them was in a medically yeah and then
they showed them seeing each other for
the first time in wheelchairs and
wheelchair they go right right next to
each other and they hug and oh my god we
cried so [ __ ] hard we cry hugged for
20 quite hard hug yeah it was two
siblings there but they grew up - yeah
it would know they were talking what the
[ __ ] you start yet they were crying okay
yeah yeah oh so it broke me up it broke
me up - damn what other families believe
and then there was another family I mean
it's here's what the thing is is that
these two brothers that the sound Yaya's
my people know that they're the guys
from Kyrgyzstan the brothers that were
radicalized oh that well yeah what they
did was we don't see as like civilians
really unless you watch a documentary
like this like the effects it has but it
affects so many people you know and it's
just these lingering effects of not not
having limbs and having to deal with the
new life that's ahead of you this yes
this paint like one girl had her leg for
a year and but she just she didn't want
to lose it but the pain was so
excruciating
excruciatingly yeah that she she had to
get an appetizer yeah and so like when
we think that oh they survive that you
know that's it yeah they're fine you
know we're happy they survive but a lot
of these people on a daily even three
years 43 years after the fact are still
completely just devastated at the fact
that they can't move on with their lives
like they're oh god it's yes I just have
to watch it I think that I would be able
to like if I was in a situation like
that where I lost legs I might be able
to move on if I lost an arm I might be
able to live but if I lost my dick no
let's be honest do you think you'd feel
sadder I'm all okay she was watching
Mandy yeah I would be able to do it okay
arms dick or legs you choose which one
arms either one but not my dick or ear
year Oh Gilbert
oh you mean losing your sight okay what
are so this what yourself
Oh a scenario is this that or let's say
this is a good scenario so look at me
Gilbert right a bomb goes off right so
you can choose between losing one of
three things your sight [ __ ] your ears
which is hearing right yeah oh you're
hearing no smell it smells or you're on
penis what would you want I just one I
choose vagina penis take that what it
with okay so well eyes and ears are
involved now penis could be something
that could go I know cuz I want to be
able to see still see cuz I want to see
like you know can I steal orgasm without
a penis no yes why why because let me
see for a woman it's we would be more
likely for us to still be able to orgasm
because we use our internal muscles
anyway yeah yeah but for men it's the
sensation of like actual ejaculation and
the liquid passing through a shorter
shaft it might be just like I don't know
I don't know you know what I would do is
I would
like if put a strong don't know what I
would do is bomb goes off right and it
looked down and if there's any left you
grab that [ __ ] no I would just grab like
I would cover it
yeah the one little piece of dick that
had left right right and and they I
would could it be in the emergency room
and their medics would become his hands
around his dick like a little okay well
when I woke up I'd go I could just tuck
it inside I'll turn into van yeah can I
ask you this yeah okay what is that's
the first thing you do with a bottle of
Ron okay a bomb explodes right then you
look around and you only find like
you're searching searching but you only
find the cap the head of the penis yeah
just a my I would grab anything that
even looked like the head like a finger
somebody else's [ __ ] penis yes chin
anything that looks like my dick you
really just grab it and wrap it and then
at the hospital I would like like you
know like a urine out archaeologist do
you know I mean like when they find like
that idea like bones and stuff I will
put it all on a little table and go
which one which one's a dick right and I
think that one I just stick it aside
let's just stick inside my [ __ ] you
just put a finger what if they say you
only could have your tip left just the
head on on the flat full in a bump would
you would you like we can attach just as
along there's feelings you know me
because the tip is all the feelings
anyway yeah it's so full like for
instance you know I could just still
move on if I can come I know it sounds
juvenile and basic it's important but
like a dumb person would say something
like that but I like coming you to more
than you like seeing or hear no I want
my eyes and my ears
yeah that's a tough part but like if I
could just have the head there like I
took a little mound right and I could
just take a bottle of water and just
squirt at it I don't know what I would
do you know I mean
just like well you know what I would do
I would just haul Larry Flynt and their
connector company or some sort of toy
company and make it just make something
you know man we're just vibrates or
something you know what I just have to
do that but [ __ ] I'd lose the penis I'm
not losing my hearing or my sight yeah
for sure
like take my vagina please movies I
cannot use movies no no music music
movies okay but would you be able to act
though if you have no dick I don't know
I'm not my dick I'm at loss he still has
all his apparatus around it no if you
lose your balls as a joint changer voice
hey you made use of all testosterone
alright so here we go here we go now
here's the real question specific things
be Bob's don't work that way listen to
me listen to me right now okay
so what about this scenario eyes ears
right but your balls and penis because
you can't act out for that whole thing
can I just say that careers yeah but
this nostril isn't necessarily made in
your ball sack where think it is no it's
made and I think I'm pretty sure it's
made in your adrenal gland like the
precursor to testosterone there's little
things that sit on top of your kidneys
what areas can you can you inject
testosterone in your body
TRT yes take T blockers like if you're
transitioning into a woman that's what
they give you they give you t
testosterone blockers yeah yeah
but don't I'm not actually sure where
they're made but I think they're made in
the adrenal gland in your body when we
talk about sexuality and stuff like that
but I just have one last question
scenario okay there's not a scenario as
a question if you lose your penis in
your balls okay and you think about sex
what happens where does the blood go oh
man did your foot get a little bigger I
mean what happens well you lose your
penis and your balls yeah you know how
you're like okay so I have my penis and
my balls are gone yeah and I'm watching
like the arrival yeah what's this girl's
name in it I mean I'm Hamming Adams you
know she's cute right there you know and
I feel aroused yeah where does the blood
go
no probably I'll get aroused then
probably in the general area but your
balls and Dicky are you getting aroused
by Amy Adams going human
[Music]